[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with Tiger
Woods et back in the director's chair
fourth or four I thought I'd break down
some of the plot leaks that we have on
the movie and everything we know so far
there will be heavy spoilers here and
whilst all leaks like this should be
taken with a grain of salt a lot of the
details have been posted by Roger
Wardell who famously broke numerous
leaks on Avengers and game long before
the movie went athere's
I'll also be discussing guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 so if you don't want
anything runed about either of the
upcoming movies then I highly recommend
that you turn off now without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now sit back relax
and let's get into my breakdown of the
Thor fall plot details ok so first
things first this week we saw
confirmation that Taika Waititi would be
coming back to write and direct Thor 4
there had been some back and forth on
this as the director was signed on to
create a film adaptation of Akira
however due to issues with the script
that film has now been born hold Disney
and Marvel reportedly one production for
Thor 4 to star as soon as possible and
this warner brothers have had to push
the project back until after were TT
finishes work on the norse gods upcoming
film but what about the plot itself well
firstly Thor is set to return in
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 which is
reportedly going to be officially
announced by Disney at San Diego Comic
Con this month this film will not be
called as guardians of the galaxy as
recently confirmed by James Gunn however
there have been more leaks from the
infamous spoiler Roger Waddell now
apparently in the film we pick up with
the group similar to how we left them in
the final scenes of Avengers endgame
they are a unit with Thor and star-lord
fighting over command and all are
attempting to track down Gamora who
disappeared at the end of the last epic
MCU movie along the way they apparently
come across the High Evolutionary who is
revealed to be Rockets creator rocket
gets a new love interest in the form of
Lyla and we are also introduced to beat
a rebel who like the former two
characters was created by the
evolutionary in addition to this Adam
warlock is introduced as the big
antagonist of the film and the movie is
set to focus on the group turning him to
the side of good
whilst he battles internally with Magus
the dark side of his personality that
eventually ends up as the overseer of
the galaxy in an alternate timeline that
may be discussed in future movies Thor
and Bri bill apparently go off and do
their own thing with the plot continuing
with the Guardian searching for Gamora
the post-credits scene apparently shows
ba ray bill and Thor working together
and then sets up their future film Thor
for in which they are joined by Korg and
meek and we see the formation of the as
guardians of the galaxy with Bill at the
helm the group are set to go
cross-dimensional and apparently the
movie is set to take place across the
multiverse with Thor discovering his
long-lost adopted brother Loki who after
the events of his Disney Plus spin-off
show has been running rampant through
the galaxy whilst details are sketchy at
the moment there are also other rumors
that the group will at some point run
into the Silver Surfer and this will
tease Galactus this will be similar to
how Black Panther was introduced in
civil war and we know Marvel are amazing
at introducing side characters that
eventually go on to do their home things
we don't know when Thor 4 is due to
begin shooting
however with James Gunn reportedly
working on and finishing up the Suicide
Squad at DC before he comes back to
Marvel there is potential that the movie
could actually finish rapping before
Guardians even though it will be
released after we saw something similar
with Captain Marvel and Avengers end
game where endgame was already filmed
and in the can before shooting started
on the Carol Danvers solo movie but we
will no doubt likely find out in detail
what's going to happen when the full
slate is launched at Comic Con either
way I think they're setting up for
another incredible slay and I trust ICO
with et to do an absolutely amazing job
on the whole thing and could definitely
see this being another incredible film
featuring the god of thunder
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on Thor 4 and if you're excited for the
upcoming film comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of the rumors that we
may be getting Kraven the hunter in
spider-man 3 and that it could be from
what kinda I'll leave that linked at the
end and hopefully I'll see you over
there after this I also just want to let
you know that we're giving away a free
copy of Avengers and
on blu-ray - one lucky winner and all
you have to do is like this video make
sure that you subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on the movie and
the comment section below the winner
will be chosen at random on August the
10th and the blu-ray will be shipped out
from then whoever gets the prize so best
of luck to everyone who takes part this
is a channel for people who are super
into superheroes so if that's the kind
of thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
you